NO PENALTIESGHT IT WAS BUT ENDED
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR OTTAWA 9 TH
IT TO CARPENTER, THE CARPENTER
CAROLINA SENATORS BRING IT
BACK. BLUE LINE.ZONE TO ZONE IN
BE TO CONTINUE TO GET  AT IT.
LOOKING FOR A SHOT, SO EVERYONE
THERE. KEEPING HIM OTTAWA NOT
ABLE TO CLEAR AND ON THE IN FRO,
AND JONES KNOCKED IT OUT OF
HARMS WAY.
THEIR GOLDEN OPPORTUNITIES IN D
GIVEN UP THERE BY THE FLOWER
AND THEN ALL GET THAT, AND TAKEY
ANY, ANY THOUGHTS TO GET BACK
IN THIS THE LEFT.
SCFRONT
OF MATT MURRAY.
MAYBE OFF OF NORIS, WITH T-- AN.
>> SOMEBODY GRAB THE PUCK.
THEY OFF FOR ON 2. IS A
INTERNATIONAL  IT UPTHAT HAPPENE
CADE, IT'S A HAT TRICK FORHIT, R
IT JUST EXPLODES, AND THAT, OF
THE COMPANY GO